I don't know what Trump wants but like
the percentage like probability that I
ascribe towards that government being
fundamentally incompetent has definitely
increased and I think amongst traders
definitely definitely it's similarly to
trust people like Liz Truss and people
like the Trump administration they are
correct in identifying that there are
massive problems in the economic system
but both of these groups of people Liz
Truss and now Donald Trump seem to think
that the way to fix the economy is to
like lock a couple of geeks in a room
for a couple of weeks and ask them to
rewrite the entire economic system all
by themselves and then to suddenly
forced some crazy poorly implemented
plan on the entire world without any
discussion and um I think it's
phenomenally immature way to do politics
and economics. I mean God knows how many
Cambodians would have died just to make
it so that poor Americans can't afford
trainers. And I'm not saying that
tariffs are a bad policy, but when are
we going to wake up to the fact that we
have serious economic problems and we
need to have a discussion about this as
a society? Why does it have to keep
being crazy people with crazy hair
bringing up crazy policies that they
seem to have like made up themselves a
week earlier, you know, in a little
meeting with four people? It's it it
drives me
mad. Oh my god.